hey guys it is Thursday my name is just
this dent and you are watching games
bunnies
first up professor has revealed that
you'll be able to customize your evil
within to experience even more than you
could in the first game the original
evil within let you customize
protagonist sebastian and his arsenal of
weapons while the sequel will let you
upgrade the two with separate resources
green gel now only upgrades your hero
while weapons can now be modified with
weapon parts in a post on its blog
bethesda added that you'll be able to
customize Sebastian's health combat
stealth recovery and athleticism
upgrading the combat tree for instance
increases the amount of damage you can
do and grants you the bullet cascade
ability which ramps up the power of
consecutive shots if you're more of a
defensive player putting points in the
health tree gives you a bigger life
gauge and more endurance the parts for
your weapons can alter your guns
abilities fire rate for an hour capacity
the evil within to is also set to
feature a pretty deep crafting system
the game is out for ps4 Xbox one and PC
on October 13th betas betas they're
everywhere these days no matter what you
call them the 2017 version of a free
demo is here to stay Nicole a junior
world war 2 multiplayer beta kicks off
soon and if you do play you'll be able
to get a bunch of bonuses activism have
announced that anyone taking part in the
beta will get the MP private beta combat
pack in it you'll get a helmet calling
card and emblem so you can show off to
your friends or enemies that's you
pre-ordered the beta kicks off first on
ps4 from August 25th to 28th the second
wave running through September 1st to
4th on ps4 and Xbox one you can get into
the beta via pre-ordering for which
you'll also get an exclusive weapon camo
to be used in the game somebody's mode
I'm personally pretty interested in Call
of Duty's returned to its roots so I'll
definitely be taking part in the beta
let us know if you'll be playing and
what you think of what you've seen so
far from sledgehammer games latest in
the comments someone's suing Rockstar
Games again so it must be a date ending
in why because I was actually really
strange it even Trump's Rockstar verse
Lindsay Lohan game oh I love their
address yeah obviously did a local film
according to big fans of the impromptu
standing office meeting TMZ psychic
readers Network has filed a lawsuit
against rockstar for the use of the
likeness of famous psychic Miss Cleo
without permission this is a really
weird one weirder than usual because
Yuri del Harris whose
was miss Claire actually voiced the
character of auntie poulet in vice city
confusing harris passed away in 2016 but
psychic readers network is claiming it
spent more than a hundred million
dollars creating and promoting this
clear and that Rockstar has profited
unfairly by having a similar character
in Vice City it's worth noting that
psychic readers network aren't strangers
to lawsuits after suing General Mills
for using miss players likeness to
promote some cereal they have also been
at the center of a Federal Trade
Commission complaint claiming their
quote entire operation is alleged to be
permeated with fraud Rockstar have
called the lawsuit entirely meritless
and completely ridiculous and have vowed
to defend themselves vigorously this
might be one to watch just for the
spectacle so make sure you subscribe so
we can keep you updated that's
everything we have for you today enjoy
the rest of your day thanks so much for
joining us and do remember that tomorrow
we'll have our top five stories of the
whole week so if you need to get caught
up you can catch us then in vice city
confusing keep up thank you pop okay pop
caifa come on come on
that's right just say something funny
but in this case it sounded like a [ __ ]